I believe you thank you son
you want to talk about it later over a
game of catch
I'd like that what's going on Family
Game Night don't worry I brought twister
you know in another lifetime you and I
would have made a hot ass couple agreed
[Music]
yes you should be very proud of yourself
I know things aren't exactly where you
want to be right now but uh I promise
you they will approve thank you Captain
every time someone steps up and says who
they are
the world becomes a better more
interesting place
so
thank you
hey do you seriously only have two wine
glasses yeah a little long well you're
gonna need to get some more because
there's a lot of us here thank you for
doing this man of course we'll be here
every week roads have I broke both of
your wine glasses in your fridge door in
your bathroom every single week
Santiago I'm on the phone
I'm so sorry sir I can come back later
no it's too late the call is ruined
goodbye dear
what do you want well since there's a
good chance that things are coming to an
end I just wanted to say thank you for
everything that you've taught me I know
you may not see yourself as my mentor
but of course I do I've been mentoring
you all this time what
this is day
1282 of a nine-year mentorship I had
mapped out for you under ordinary
circumstances I wouldn't reveal this to
you until day 3300. it was really
there was a binder not anymore
you'll Mentor me if we don't work
together we could meet for breakfast
every day you could teach me over eggs
eggs for breakfast further behind than I
thought no look okay there are 10 hours
left sir if you talk fast enough you can
teach me everything
okay
take notes do you think you can keep up
let's just say I was president of the
stenographers Club in high school for a
reason was the reason because you were
the only member
yes
five minutes left what have I missed
professional handshake we did that
fingers with a half centimeter spread up
down then separated good acceptable
Fabrics cotton or cotton blend will list
for outerwear only and silk is for sex
workers or musicians right good desserts
there are none if you were hungry you
should have had more dinner that's it
we're done
you've been mentored oh my God
my god oh no
yes I agree up down separation
I'm so glad you're helping me maybe I
won't blow it after all
you'll do plenty of blowing of that
flute now let's go a five six seven
eight
stops the not meant start now not start
one second later again five six seven
eight
[Music]
are you playing the muffin man or the
garbage man huh do you know the garbage
man because I do because I'm looking
right at him again five six seven eight
[Applause]
[Music]
um
okay
[Applause]
why'd you stop playing garbage man I
need some water what you need to do is
keep practicing garbage man I don't have
any more saliva and I don't have any
more time for
man now play I
get five six I don't want your help
anymore I'm not a garbage man I'm a
muffin man hi my name is Terry Jeffords
and I don't know how this is gonna go
wait
sir I'm captain Raymond Holt of the 99th
Precinct and I need to tell you about
this man now the audition Piece he's
about to play may not be technically
perfect in fact it may hurt your ears
you may consider it an insult to music
you may whisper to each other muffin man
more like garbage man come on but you
would be wrong this man has taught me
something he's taught me that music is
about heart and soul it's about
perseverance despite everything I put
him through
showed up here today
and you would be a fool not to put him
in your band thank you Captain so again
your Alibi is a mysterious stranger
handed you the gun made you put your
prince on it robbed the store and then
hid the gun in your underpants Well yeah
if you say it like that it don't sound
believable oh hey Captain did you get my
report on the Finley murder oh yeah
looked it over nice word good thanks Dad
why is everyone staring at me you just
called Captain hold dad he said thanks
Dad what no I didn't I said thanks man
do you see me as a father figure Peralta
no if anything I see you is a bother
figure because you're always bothering
me hey show your father some respect I
didn't call him Dad no no no no Jacob I
take it as a compliment it's not a big
deal I called Vivian mom once she's my
fiance guys jump on that Boyle has
psychosexual shoes old news but you
calling Holt daddy daddy is not on the
table here but you did call him dead
dude you shut up you've done nothing but
lie since you got here all right all
right I was lying about the holdup but
the dad thing that happened
he admitted that his Alibi was a lie it
was a trap all part of my crazy devious
plan I believe you thank you son
you want to talk about it later over a
give him a catch
I'd like that you took a vacation 14
days ago and yet you already want
another day off odd unless you need it
for a unique once in a lifetime
occurrence perhaps a proposal to your
girlfriend Jocelyn what you've been
dating for a year you met each other's
parents and you just got your nails done
to present her with a ring
Jocelyn broke up with me what I want the
day off so I can sit alone listen to
death metal and get my head right but
what about my nail polish solve getting
my nails done made me feel better for a
second
this is a trick to throw me off I bet
things are better than ever and you oh
you really are crying Rosa stop I give
up I want you to know I'm sorry for
prying win this thing and enjoy your day
off and if you ever want a friend to sit
with you and silently listen to death
metal just know
I'm always here okay
I'd like that
no what are you freaks doing we're
leaving the competition some things are
more important than a game no they're
not
you like it not at all you can leave not
a chance
[Music]
is this thing taken
you're really gonna do this Diaz my name
is Rachel Weinstein I'm a graduate
student on sabbatical to study birds at
the University of Buenos Aires you know
Cornell has a far better Ornithology
department and it's right here in New
York Cornell has accused me of robbing a
bank and is going to send me to jail for
15 years I guess we're dropping the
metaphor I don't know why you're here
you're not going to change my mind I
know
I just wanted to say goodbye okay
goodbye I hope you know your family's
gonna miss you I don't care I really
speak to them I was talking about the
nine nine be safe Richard Weinstein
[Music]
well I don't say that a lot there's one
thing I still don't understand
did you know you had the wrong murder
weapon oh excellent question sir yes I
spotted the missing Dental award when I
first took the case I asked around weeks
ago it turns out a cleaning lady knocked
it over and shattered it then why did
you run in there like that because in
talking to you I realized what Philip's
worst fear actually was that we would
think he was just some dummy that got
lucky right he had planned the perfect
crime and it killed him when you said he
was sloppy and impulsive he needed us to
know how smart he was hi
like someone else I know
yep
Kevin
I'm probably brought
thank you sir
no let's go get some sleep hey guys
my goodness we're almost late for word
no well in that case
good morning sir good morning
God I love this job
[Music]
so
you're leaving
I must have been a hard decision
honestly
it wasn't it's funny on my first day
here I asked Jeffers to tell me about
everyone told me you were a great
detective but the one thing you couldn't
figure out was how to grow up
well
I think you finally figured it out
well thank you sir I couldn't have done
it without you over the years you've
sometimes referred to me as something of
a father figure did I I didn't realize
that but I want you to know if I had had
a son
and uh it turned out like you
I would be very proud of them
thank you sir
wow
wasn't expecting to get this emotional
it's not bad for an old robot huh
more sleep
sir did you just make a joke I believe I
did yes I guess in the end we rubbed off
on each other quite a bit
title of your sex movie
did I do that right
it was perfect
all right